[Music]
forget cutting carbs
it turns out the real culprit in our
diets is carbon
over one third of total greenhouse gas
emissions come from food production
to stick to climate targets we need to
change what we eat and how we produce it
fortunately new technologies could
create a more sustainable future
from lab-grown meat and gourmet insects
to radical new ways of farming
but with almost 10 billion mouths to
feed by 2050
can these new solutions really feed the
world and reduce carbon emissions
our experts answer your questions
why is it so important to make food
systems more sustainable
it's important to make food systems more
sustainable because food production
generally and beef production in
particular is a huge emitter of
greenhouse gases beef emits more than 30
times the amount of carbon per calorie
as tofu but it's not just beef
production the way we produce
crops in particular
wheat corn monocrops like that has an
effect on biodiversity it also uses a
tremendous amount of fertilizer and the
runoff from that fertilizer creates
enormous dead zones in our literal seas
so the reason why it's important to make
food production more sustainable is to
avoid those sorts of harms to avoid the
damage to the oceans and to avoid the
the immense amount of greenhouse gases
that are emitted
will we all have to give up eating meat
reducing consumption of certainly what
we currently think of as meat is almost
certainly part of a move to a more
sustainable way of eating
demand for meat and fish is growing
particularly among the rapidly expanding
middle classes in developing countries
and
producing meat in an old-fashioned way
raising animals killing them and eating
them is incredibly resource intensive
and so that's why we're now thinking
about both plant-based alternatives and
lab-grown alternatives to meat
can lab-grown meat be scaled up and made
affordable
yeah that's really the billion dollar
trillion dollar question right now that
the industry is asking itself it has
been shown to be possible to produce
meat in a lab
at small scale though
it's going to be really difficult to
scale it up for a couple of reasons
number one most lab-grown meat comes
from cells that are fed with fetal
bovine serum this is the growth medium
that they're given this is a substance
taken from pregnant cows at slaughter
it's variable in quality it's expensive
it's difficult to imagine meat for
billions of people being made using this
serum there are synthetics that are
being developed but those synthetics
aren't quite there yet and the price of
lab-grown meat is never going to be less
than the price of the growth medium that
they're grown in so this is one
bottleneck a second question about
making it more affordable at scale just
has to do with with how many people
want it i mean it's going to have to
replace a significant portion of
our meat consumption
to actually make a dent to actually
deliver on its environmental and ethical
promises the way the meat industry works
in rich countries is that it produces
affordable meat for
a lot of people that's an incumbent
system that it's really going to be hard
to compete with on price but there are a
lot of people who are doing it and i
think a lot a lot a lot really rides on
it being done
could new foods be developed with added
nutrients and vitamins
so we already fortify certain foods with
particular vitamins it's quite common to
add iron to flour that's used in
commercially produced bread to try and
address anemia in populations it's
possible to breed plants that have
higher levels of nutrients
like zinc or vitamin a but what's
striking about this question when you
relate it to something like a
plant-based burger is that that's a food
that you are building from the ground up
you're creating it and that allows you
to tweak the recipe to
change the components that you're using
to make it
as you go along and so there's certainly
potential
for thinking about the nutritional
contents of these products
i think that's absolutely right and it's
not just plant-based burgers that you're
building from scratch that's also true
when you're doing lab-grown meat so
companies can genetically edit the cells
of the meat they produce to make them
rich in fiber for instance you can have
a hamburger that has fiber in it you can
have a chicken cutlet that's loaded with
omega-3s which you now only find from
fish so they're just tremendous
opportunities to improve the nutritional
quality of foods that we eat whether
customers will accept it is another
question but the opportunity is
certainly there
why is everyone talking about eating
insects
raising insects for consumption doesn't
produce greenhouse gases
insects can convert nutrients and water
into protein far more efficiently than a
lot of animals that we currently think
of as as fit for consumption and they
also contain a lot more protein
than
various legumes and even than some other
kinds of
meats and eggs so they're a really
meaningful alternative to the current
sources of protein that we eat
and around two billion people in the
world already eat them on a regular
basis
should we return to traditional
small-scale farming and is it possible
to feed everyone that way
so there are a lot of problems with the
current food system the cruelty that's
inflicted upon animals and large-scale
meat production the way in which workers
are treated
and
a kind of local organic small scale
farming can seem like a solution to that
to those problems especially
to richer people in richer countries
the problem with offering that as a
solution to the problems in our in our
food system is that it doesn't really
address the actual flaws that exist
today
yeah i think josie is absolutely right
there's certainly
nothing wrong with opting for local
small-scale choices if you have the
money to do that if it's possible to do
that but it doesn't address the systemic
problems in the industry as josie said
and it's also difficult to imagine that
that is a solution
at scale right what we're talking about
here is changing an entire food system
what a preference for small scale local
farming does essentially opt you out of
the food system which is fine for
reasons of personal conscience but again
doesn't sort of address the bigger
problems in the food system itself
why is vertical farming more sustainable
vertical farms
avoid the risk of fertilizer runoff
they control their product much more
precisely than than traditional soil
farming does
they can get food to consumers closer to
where they live so there's a decrease in
the amount of of food miles traveled but
they do use a tremendous amount of
energy now that's going to
matter less as the world's energy
sources become more renewable but
there's a big upfront energy cost right
now so i don't know that it's right to
say that they're they're they're
completely more sustainable as as they
currently exist but vertical farming is
clearly a part of our agricultural
future as the world's energy sources get
greener so too will vertical farming
will consumers accept new foods like lab
grow meat and insects
i mean 500 years ago people in europe
were not keen on eating potatoes and 50
years ago if you'd gone into most
western supermarkets i don't think you
would have found
boxes of sushi or jars of kimchi and
those are things that we now in the west
eat with great enthusiasm changing
eating habits is hard because food is an
emotional and a cultural thing but i
don't think it's impossible
thanks very much for watching you can
read more about the future of food and
my technology quarterly by clicking the
link and please don't forget to
subscribe